but they have a real problem people
killing predators and I believe it's the
same problem they have with like Cecil
the lion and [ __ ] like that they think
that you're just doing it to be an
[ __ ] and you just want this thing on
your wall well I'm gonna head on your
wall I do have some contention and you
tell me and like like for instance like
the grizzly bear issue being shut down
in BC no he's a bear grizzly bear
hunting maybe you can explain that from
yeah I don't understand what's going on
yeah so so the government the British
Columbia government shutdown british
columbia british columbia grizzly bear
hunting because they equated it and i
guess they're probably correct with
trophy hunting right where hunters were
killing these animals and just taking
the skulls and hides and leaving the
flesh behind and and i don't know i've
never have i i've grizzly bear hunted
NBC wants but i was actually more on a
sheep on but yeah just this notion of
like like the gentleman that killed
Cecil the lion like if you're really
going to kill an animal and just take
its hide then I've pretty significant
issue with that and so like I just hope
these hunters that the guys that were
hunting the grizzly bears I just I
wonder if this was more of a hunter
instilled issue then then people are
even bringing light into it because if
people were killing grizzly bears in
British Columbia taking their hides
taking their skulls and taking all the
flesh I feel like we'd still be grizzly
bear hunting in British Columbia I don't
know I mean maybe maybe but grizzly
bears are another notch up even above
black bears in terms of like correct
yeah what Rinella calls charismatic
megafauna people love those things like
that see them yeah and if you don't have
to deal with them if you don't like that
guy in Anna's Colorado last year that
got his head cut open by one if you
don't have to deal with them you know
they are amazing to look at and we all
want them around and of course they're
an incredible animal but it's this thing
of trophy hunting these what you think
of some fat lazy [ __ ] with a rifle
that stands on top of a lion
you know there's is this image that I
found online and I was looking I was
like that is that's why people have a
problem
trophy sauna 5 this fat [ __ ] who should
never in a million years without that
rifle had have ever the help yeah or the
help especially the help right mm-hmm
like there's no way he would have got on
it there's nobody who got to that
position he must have got there in a car
you know and then they have this line
there and he's perched up on the line
like he did some amazing thing yeah and
meanwhile that's probably one of those
caged lions anyway it is mean yeah they
have so many of those high fence hunts
where they let these Lions they have
them all caged up in a pen they throw
cows over the dead cows over the pen
over the wall the pen the lines tearing
apart and then they pick one and take
that one out into the the you know
wilderness area which is all fenced in
anyway and then they let it loose and
the the lion stays in the area because
it has no idea what its boundary is what
its territory is what other lions are in
that area
so a lot of times they sit still and
they wait for a while before they figure
out what their territory is the hunter
comes in shoots it stands on it takes a
picture I mean you shot a pet if you if
you told me he said hey man I went into
Tanzania I went into you know the
wildest part and back packed in and set
up camp and I was there for 40 days and
you know I killed killed an eight plains
game and I worked with the locals and
and and you know I shared meat with
these different tribes and and man and
we found a pride of lions and there was
a giant maned male and there's another
sister pride over here and we you know
we snuck in and we kill them we hunted
him we killed him you know we skinned
him out we took his flesh and we went on
an honest hunt and we engaged the wild
here and we removed an animal wicked I
would love to read that book I'd love to
see that film I'd love to hear you tell
me that story but does anybody eat lions
why that's I'm saying that's I'm saying
I does anybody I don't know I never even
heard of it I've never been in Africa
and if and if you're not one then what
are we doing I understand killing is so
there's there's some right
weirdness there too because if you told
me if you called me and said hey man I'm
gonna pay you a million dollars I want
you to come down to my concession I get
these offers daily not a million dollars
but if you come down will you come down
on my concession and shoot a giraffe I'm
just making this up but I'm trying to
pick a zoo animal right well you come
down and shoot a giraffe I'd love to see
you come down and film this blah blah
and you know the answer is no I had no
explain a concession to people to this
large areas that most the time fenced in
yet a lot of thousands thousands maybe
even tens of thousands of acres like
you're never going to see the fence we
could drive you around in there for a
week and you never see this oh it's semi
wild yeah the fence thing is very weird
right because like their habitat the
fence essentially keeps people out yeah
protects them from poachers yeah it's
not it's not necessarily to trap the
animals although the animals can't leave
it's to keep the poachers out rights to
preserve these areas because people with
greed will take they'll kill anything to
get a few dollars in the marketplace for
for market meat and then certainly to
sell a hide to maybe even an even more
fat hunter that or person that calls
themselves a hunter that wants a lion on
their wall that doesn't even want to
engage in the process right they'll buy
the skin or something that's why there's
trade and tire skins and things like
this but and so in these concessions and
so these you know if you called me and
said hey Abel you come down and shoot a
giraffe you know I'll pay a million
bucks to come down and shoot a draft you
know the answer is no I don't want to
kill a drop but if you called me and
said hey we have restored this habitat
in this whole River Delta and lo and
behold the giraffes have absolutely
taken off and they're very very
successful and they're decimating the
vegetation here and they're starting to
fight each other with great severity and
we're finding dead bulls and stuff we
need to remove ten animals from this
herd will you come down and shoot ten
giraffes with me understand absolutely
like if I can come down and contribute
to the ecology of an area either as a
hunter or as somebody that's just
removing animals with a high-powered
rifle to create some more balance I'm
all into it but if I'm gonna pay you
$70,000
to get a big mainline so I can have my
photo with a big maned lion that I can
show my friends be like oh yeah that's
when I was in Botswana and that's all I
could tell you that story and no
interest in it and I think some of that
stuff is maybe really poisonous for
hunting I think it's very poisonous I
think that Cecil the lion story was
incredibly poisonous yeah it was one of
those stories where it was almost
impossible to find any support for the
guy who did that thing and you know and
it was legal it was I mean you know
people say what was a collared lion yeah
well you can't really tell like they
have giant Mane's even if it was it
doesn't mean anything you can shoot
colored animals yeah and they're not
collared because they're protected it's
not like the idea is like you could
never shoot it because it's collared
yeah and you know it's the it's just not
what people you just it's real hard to
justify if you're not eating it
I mean why why would you want to do it
why would you want to go and hunt a lion
doesn't make any sense you'd have to be
an [ __ ] that guy's not asking himself
any questions I'll tell you that right
Yeah right why is he doing it because
that's what he likes to do and so that's
why I wonder like I haven't grizzly bear
hunted in British Columbia but I wonder
and I'm not I have lots of friends there
that our guides and Outfitters and I
understand that the meat I've heard it's
gross I've heard it's grows too but I
mean you know yeah how is it and
fantastic